we have a challenge from somebody
calling themselves
magnus best one and all the friends of
the
program know that i'm a sucker for
these silly nicknames so i'm gonna give
my nice best one again
we'll go go i'm going to go for the
keracon in this game
ed5 comes very soon
so i'm gonna treat
my opponent to what i played against
ding
in the um in the tour
finals quite recently
and my opponent seems very much booked
up on theory
playing very fast although ding went
rook ae1 there
in order to organize an attack
he's easier i think now with uh
without the rook and
sorry with the with the fruit t1 it's
easier for me to justify
castling quickly because there's less of
a chance of an attack happening then
on the on the king side
change for queen c6
and b5 trying to get that
minority attack going
usually
with the turks nah i'm not going to go
there
no jokes and minority attacks obviously
uh we go for b5 and then a5
and um yeah my
my position seems fairly
easy to play now it's all about getting
b4
or a4 knight c4 at some point
by the way if anybody if anybody is
wondering about
the shirt or yeah the shirt it's not
actually a shirt it's a football jersey
um
yeah so you can see that team is
manchester city and
i'll give you one guess to say who
to guess who's whose name is on the back
mind you this this jersey was born
was bought i think in 2017 or maybe
2018.
well so in the game we have uh
my opponent is playing very solidly i'm
trying to claim
that i'm a little bit better with uh
with a slightly more compact pawn
structure but i think realistically it's
not a lot
but i'm still claiming of course
always claiming now trying to
provoke the exchange of bishops and then
i'm going to go knight b5 or knight f5
attacking d4 knight e5 is very good
now knight f3 i think will happen
and i go f6 trying to
oh rook c6 was missed
that is a major problem
that is actually a major major problem
the point now is that i wanted to go
rook b8 and then
king f7 but now i don't have time
because
rook b6 is a major threat once i
protect the pun so now i really don't
know what to do
really don't know
yeah i think i i just have to go for
something very drawing here so if i go
on king f7
rook b6 would have happened and i would
have had no good square for the
knights this is not a good move king g3
because the knight c3 that's an
important mistake
um my opponent should have played rook
b6 there
printing the rook i would have gone rook
b3 threatening to on pin with knight d4
and i mean i'm still claiming no 92 what
happened so it's an equal position there
otherwise i could have claimed a small
advantage but now with the knight coming
to e4
possibly even e2 i am
quite a lot better
knight g1 doesn't seem to help i go
knight e4
and i win the pawn with work takes f2
next move and then
i have a huge advantage which i think in
this is gonna be it's gonna be enough to
win
we've got g5 improving the pawn
structure
slightly uh
he's attacking my king making it run up
the board which i don't mind at all
um no i was wrong i have to i have to go
back
now rook day to go knight c3
he attacks
the knight again i go knight d1
intending 93
rook d8 now knight e3 did not see my
threat
now my magnus best
opponent it's gonna be in a lot of
trouble 91 rookie two
now now it's time to collect
96 is not really a problem
that is one check only on g7
one more check then i take the knight
and that's game over so
very solid game for my opponent
um kept it up for a while and then it
was only one blender i think with uh
with uh with nida
with um start with king g3 there which
allowed max c3
which made all the difference
okay i don't know if people are actually
guessing this uh but i will
just for fun i will show the shirt
sorry the jersey to the camera
at the end of the session
but not quite yet